[موسيقى]
وهذه اخبار الساعه
اوكرانيا هجوم من نوع اخر كيف تشن حربا
على ايلون ماسك وتتهمه باخفاء التغريدات
والتلاعب بها لصالح روسيا
العربيه تتنقل في مخبي اهم احزاب المعارضه
الايرانيه هجمات مستمره من النظام
واستفزازات لجر الحزب لصراع العسكري
بعد يوم على زياره بلينكنا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تبدا بهدم منازل ومنشات
فلسطينيه وبنكفير يحرم الاسرى من الخبز
بايدن ينجو من مازق جديد محامي الرئيس
يؤكد عدم العثور على اي وثائق سريه في
منزل ديلور بعد التفتيش الاخير
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
هجوم من نوع اخر في اوكرانيا ليس على ارض
المعركه ولا في ساحات التراشق التهديدات
بل هو هجوم في فضاء تويتر فقد شنا ميخاليو
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
هجوما حدا على رئيس مجلس اداره تويتر
ايلون ماسك وقال انه يقلل من وصول
التغريدات التي تدعم اوكرانيا وجه رساله
لايلون ماسك قال فيها ان جهوده لاخفاء
التغريدات التي تدعم اوكرانيا واضحه واضاف
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني في رسالته لماسك
لا تساعد الدعايه الروسيه خصوصا ان سمعه
تويتر تموت على حد وصف مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني
وعموما كل المؤشرات في اوكرانيا لا تنظر
سوى بالتصعيد فمساله ارسال الاسلحه
الغربيه الاكياف تثير مزيدا من التعقيد في
الحرب وتقلق روسيا كثيرا فبعد الجدل حول
الدبابات اعلنت واشنطن تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه بعيده المدى لاول مره منذ بدء
الحرب مسؤولون امريكيون افادوا بان واشنطن
تعد حزمه مساعده عسكريه بقيمه 2.2 مليار
دولار ومن المتوقع ان تشمل سلاحا بعيدا
المدى كمعدات دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
وذخائر دقيقه التوجيه وصواريخ جابلن
متوسطه المدى المضاده للدبابات بحسب ما
اكل المسؤولون
في اوكرانيا يرتفع سقف المساعدات العسكريه
لاول مره حزمه مساعدات الامريكيه جديده
لاوكرانيا
صواريخ طويله المدى
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه الاوكرانيا
تشمل معدات دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
[موسيقى]
المضاده للدبابات
من المتوقع ان تشمل المساعدات ايضا
المركبات المقاومه للالغام وانظمه اطلاق
الصواريخ المتعدده الموجهه والذخيره
تبلغ قيمه تلك المساعدات مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار
وهذه الحزمه الامريكيه اقلقت روسيا التي
حذرت على لسان المتحدث باسمها اكد ان
الصواريخ الاطول مدى ستفاقم الصراع وان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ليس لديه اي
خطط لعقد محادثات مع نظيره الامريكي
همم حتى الان لا توجد خطط لاجراء محادثات
بين بوتين هدفن الرئيسي الان هو مواصله
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ونهدف ايضا الى
تنفيذ المهام المحدده هناك مستجدات في
الوقت الحاضر نرى ان البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للناتو تعملو ضد الاتحاد الروسي
كما ان البنيه التحتيه الاستطلاعيه للناس
باكملها في ذلك الطائرات هو الاقمار
الصناعيه تعمل على مدار الساعه طوال ايام
الاسبوع لصالح اوكرانيا بالطبع كل هذا
يخلق ظروفا عاديا لا يسعنا الى ان ناخذها
في الاعتبار
وفي اطار دعم العسكري لاوكرانيا نقل موقع
اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين قولهم ان
حكومه نتنياهو تجري مراجعه للسياسه
الاسرائيليه تجاه حرب اوكرانيا اضاف
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون ان المراجعه تتضمن
امكانيه امدادي كييف بانظمه دفاعيه اوضح
ان نتنياهو امر بهذه المراجعه بعد وقت
قصير من عودته لمنصبه
ردا على ذلك حذرت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه
من تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح زخاربا اكدت ان
اي سلاح يتم تزويد اوكرانيا به سيكون هدفا
مشروعا للقوات الروسيه
حول بيان الجانب الاسرائيلي بشان تزويد
اوكرانيا بالسلاح نحن لا نقسم الدول وفق
مبدا جغرافي ما نقول ان جميع الدول التي
تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تفهم اننا
سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهدافا مشروعه للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه
ومشاهدينا بعيدا عن الاسلحه بعيده المدى
التي تنوي واشنطن تزويد بها فالدبابات
التي تسير على سكه الوصول الى اوكرانيا
اصبحت مهدده وبشكل علني المؤسسه الروسيه
الحكوميه لتطوير وانتاج وتصدير المنتجات
الصناعيه عاليه التقنيه روستيخ اعلنت ان
دباباتو الالمانيه يمكن تدميرها بواسطه
المنظومات المضاده للدبابات الروسيه مثل
الكورنيت وصواريخ بيخاك الجويه بالاضافه
الى قذائف 125 ملم من طرازمانجو روستخ
اوضح ايضا ان دبابات على عكس الدبابات
الروسيه ليس لديها حمايه ديناميكيه
وبالتالي ليس لديها ما يحميها من الصواريخ
الروسيه فاخر واتاكا التي تستخدمها للقوات
الجويه الروسيه بنجاح لتدمير المركبات
المدرعه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
وغيرها من الدبابات وفي الطريق الى
اوكرانيا اسلحه متطوره اخرى النصر قد لا
يكون هو المقصود بكل المساعدات العسكريه
تلك
الدبلوماسيه جائز الهدف يختبئ خلف تلك
الاسلحه الحديثه
جذب الرئيس الروسي الى طاوله المفاوضات
وكسر حاله الجمود التصعيد لخفض التصعيد
بحسب
امريكا وحلفائها يعملون على تحديث
استراتيجياتهم في حرب اوكرانيا بثلاث طرق
تحديد اهداف الحرب ومنها استعاده بعض
الاراضي من قبضه روسيا ارسال اسلحه اكثر
تطورا يمكنها اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه
استهداف بعض الاماكن الاستراتيجيه المهمه
لدى روسيا باستخدام الاسلحه بعيده المدى
ومنها شبه جزيره القرم افضل طريقه اجبار
الرئيس الروسي على التفاوض بجديه ان شعر
بفقدان الجزيره المهمه
هو مسعى الرئيس الامريكي والحلفاء مساعده
اوكرانيا على زياده الضغط على القوات
الروسيه وتحويل مسار الحرب اكثر لصالحها
كطريق اكثر للمفاوضات بعد انتهاء المرحله
التاليه من القتال عصام عبد السلام
العربيه
معنا الان من نواشنطن اندروبيك نائب
مساعدي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون
ايراننا والعراق سابقا اندرو اهلا بكم
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه كان هناك
اصرار غربي وامريكي على ان اي امداد عسكري
لاوكرانيا لن يكون فيه اسلحه بعيده المدى
واسلحه يمكن ان تصل الى العمق الروسي فما
الذي تغير الان
ورمت الكريم
قد تغير
فارى ان الولايات المتحده وحلفائها يرونه
بان دبابات ابرامز ولبت اثنين وكذلك ان
شاء الله الجزء سوف تؤدي الى روسي
والاسلحه بعيد المدى التي يمكن ان يصل
المداعي الى اكثر من 200 م يمكن ان تصل
الى
رغبه اوكرانيا في ذلك هذه الاسلحه لا تزال
بعيده المنال
ولكن هناك حديث على انه امكانيه ارسال هذه
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا الان اندرو هل هذا
ربما فقط في اطار الضغط السياسي حتى تجلس
موسكو الى طاوله المفاوضات همم وانهاء هذه
الحرب
هناك مساله بهذا الشان احداهما هي ان
استراتيجيه اوكرانيا برمتها كانت تركز على
منع روسيا من
استخدام قوتها العسكريه من خلال ضرب
المخازن مخازن الاسلحه وذخائر خرفه الخطوط
الدفاعيه ومنع روسيا من التركيز على منطقه
مهاجمتها بالمدفعيه
فبالتالي فان اسلحه مثل الهاي مارس التي
سلمناها في يونيو الماضي هي لا تزال قيد
البحث ولم يتم تسليمها بعد اما بالنسبه
لجلب بوتين لاتفاوض ان صراحه اعتقد انه
سوف يكون راغبا في ذلك اذا ما حصل او
احتفظ بكل ما حصل عليه ربما اكثر من ذلك
بقليل ولكنه بالتاكيد هو لن يقبل باقل مما
لديه في رانيا الان واذا طال امد الحرب
خاصه في ذو الحصول اوكرانيا على الدبابات
فهذا سيحسن موقف اوكرانيا
ودونا التصعيد الروسي يمكن البحث عن وقف
الاطلاق النار بشروط افضل في المستقبل
حتى لو لم تكن حزمه المساعدات العسكريه
الجديده تشمل صواريخ بعيده المدى فان
الامر يستفز روسيا كثيرا هناك من يقول لا
تستفز بوتن كثيرا لانه يمكن ان يذهب الى
رده فعل مختلفه همم يعني ليس الذهاب الى
التفاوض بل للعكس تماما النتيجه عكس تماما
ما رايك
صحيح ولكن في بالمعنى التقليدي وبلاسلحه
التقليديه فان بوتين قد استخدم كل ما لديه
في حرب اوكرانيا
اي اسلحه تقليديه اخرى يمكن ان يستخدمه
السؤال الاساسي الاساسي
اتجاه شبه جزيره القرم وهذا ما لم ترغب به
الولايات المتحده حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك
اند روبيك انت نائب مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي لشؤون ايران والعراق سابقا كتب
معنا من واشنطن
قال وزير الدفاع الالماني بوريس بيستو
ريوس اثناء زيارته السريه او زياره لسريه
جيش حيث توجد
التي تجهز الارسال الى اوكرانيا قال ان
على برلين ان تطلب انتاج دبابات يوهارد
جديده لتعويض الدبابات التي ستصلها
المانيا الى
الحقيقه الحاسمه انه يتعين علينا طلب
دبابات جديده ليس في غضون ام بل باسرع وقت
حتى يمكن بدء الانتاج ويمكننا التخطيط متى
سيكون لدينا عدد دبابات الجديده من اين
ستاتي الاموال دعني اتحدث بصراحه عن هذا
السؤال بصراحه لا اهتم الامر نفسه ينطبق
على امداداته ذخيره اعاده الامداد المستمر
امر مهم وكذلك فيما يتعلق بمساله مدافع
والمركبه المدرعه الاخرى
[موسيقى]
وعلى الارض اقرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بتقدم القوات الروسيه في معركه باخمه رغم
خسائرها مشيره الى ان معارك عنيفه تدور في
الجبهه الشرقيه عمليا تمكنت القوات
الروسيه من تطبيق باخبط من ثلاثه محاور
وتعمل على طرد القوات الاوكرانيه من
مواقعها واكدت سلطات المحليه في جمهوريه
لوغانستان الشعبيه ان القوات الروسيه
تحاول الان التقدم الى مدينه
بشكل مكثف القوات الروسيه تعمل وايضا بشكل
منهجي على قطع الخطوط الامداد والاتصال
على القوات الاوكرانيه في باخبط وحصرها
بين فكي كماشه في حين تدور المعارك في
ضواحي المدينه وتحديدا في تلك الاحياء
التي ساعدت عليها الوحدات الاوكرانيه
ومؤخرا وفق السلطات المحليه
[موسيقى]
وفي خدمه التطورات المدنيه في اوكرانيا
وزخم المساعدات الغربيه
حظرت فيها الاتحاد الاوروبي من بناء امال
على رمال متحركه تتعلق بانضمام اوكرانيا
سريعا الى التكتل ياتي هذا قبيله قمه
المقرره ان يضغط الرئيس الاوكراني في
الاردن
وكيانا من دول عادي قوي وقالت الوزاره في
بيان لها ان الاشخاص المشمولين بالعقوبات
على صله بشبكه عالميه تتملص من العقوبات
على روسيا وبحسب الوزاره فان الشبكه
سيقودها تاجر سلاح يدعى ايجار ازميكم
ويتخذوا من قبرص مقر له وتعمل الشبكه على
انداد الاجهزه التكنولوجيه المتطوره الى
روسيا
الغرب هو منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا لم يكف عن فرض العقوبه عليها
وعلى اقتصادها لكن فعاليه في هذه العقوبه
يبدو انها خيبت امال الغرب والدليل
التوقعات الصادره عن صندوق النقد الدولي
الذي كشف ان الانتاج الروسي يتوسع بنسبه
0.3 هذا العام واثنين فاصل واحد بالمئه
العمل المقبل في تحدي للتنبؤات السابقه
متحدثا من الصندوق قال انه عند مستوى الحد
الاقصى الحليب لاسعار النفق
لا يتوقع ان تتاثر احجام صادرات النفط
الخام الروسي بشكل كبير مع استمرار اعاده
توجيه التجاره الروسيه من الدول التي تفرض
عقوبات الى تلك التي لا تفرد عليك تقرير
لصحيفه نيويورك الامريكيه كشف ان روسيا
تتحايل على العقوبات الدوليه من خلال
استيراد ما تحتاجه من بضائع عبر ارمينيا
وتركيا والصين وبلاسيا وكذاخستان
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه المستمره فيها بعد قليل في
بريطانيا اضراب ان هو الاكبر منذ عقد اكثر
من نصف مليون شخص يطالبون بتحسين الاجور
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
على الحدود ايراني
[موسيقى]
خمسه احزاب ايرانيه معارضه كرديات تنشط في
المهجر اهم
الديمقراطيه الكردستانيه الايرانيه
المعارض حزب قوميه يقول انه ليس متشددا
ولم انفصاليا نحن اليوم في جبل الحلقه
الاولى
في هذا الجبل على بعد كيلو متر واحد من
الحدود الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
وسط جبال كردستان العراق يتحصل مقاتلون
معارضه الايرانيه لكنها لا تحجب رؤيه
ورقابه النظام
مرحبا بكم كاول وسيله اعلام تصل الى هذا
المكان نحن قريبون من الحدود الايرانيه
وهي منطقه تتعرض باستمرار لتهديد الطائرات
المسيره والصواريخ الايرانيه
تتهم طهران الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض بدعم المظاهرات الاخيره
اثاره الشغب انطلاقا من اراضي العراق تهمه
النفاهه الحزب لكن الحرس الثوري استمر في
شان ضربات متتاليه على مواقعه ومخابئه في
كردستان العراق
[تصفيق]
هذه صور حصريه لقناه العربيه تظهر القصف
الذي شناه النظام الايراني على مواقع
الحزب في نوفمبر الماضيه
نفذت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه هجمات بطائرات
وصواريخ في محاوله لاستفزازنا لنشر قوات
البشمركه حاول النظام تقويض الانتفاضه
المدنيه عبر جرنا الى صراع عسكري
كان الحزب الديمقراطي كردستاني الايراني
حجر اساسي اول دوله كرديه في مهاباد
الايرانيه عام
1946 قبل ان تسقط ليعود الحزب الى
المشاركه في الثوره الايرانيه ضد الشاه لم
تنتهي القصه هنا طويت صفحه الشاه وفتحت
صفحه الخميني
منذ اثر المرشد الايراني الخميني عام
1979 فتوى ضد من سماهم بالمتمردين الاكراد
وكان يقصد حينها الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه التي طالبت
بالديمقراطيه والحكم الذاتي منذ ذلك الحين
بدات هذه الاحزاب صراعا مع السلطه صراع
دفع بعضهم الى مغادره البلاد واقامه
معسكرات في كردستان العراق
للاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه هنا مكاتب
ومقرات تنشط فيها سياسيا كما لها مخابئ
ومواقع للتدريب على السلاح ان كانت تشدد
على ان المواجهه المسلحه مع النظام مؤجره
الان
طبعا امل ولا اجبر على استخدام السلاح
ولكن اذا اضطرنا الى ذلك فسنستخدم الاسلحه
ليس فقط ضد الحارس الثوري الايراني ولكن
ضد اي شخص يريد سلبي حريتنا
[موسيقى]
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
المتحده
المركزي لتخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه تصل الى
60% في محطه
الوكاله الذريه ان ايران ابلغتها بتحولها
لاستخدام اجهزه طرد المركزي الجديده بعد
ان تم اكتشافها مشيره الى ان ايران تغيرت
في تصميمات تستخدم في انتاج اليورانيوم
دون ابلاغ الوكاله واعتبر وكاله الطاقه
الذريه عند اجراءات ايران تقود القدره على
تنفيذ تدابير الضمانات
هذا هو اعتبرت الوزيره الفرنسيه للشؤون
الاوروبيه للرسبان ان النظام الايرانيه
يغرق في حاله من الانكار ونظريه المؤامره
وقالت الوزيره الفرنسيه ان العقوبات التي
قال النظام الايراني انه فرضها على
الاوروبيين تدل على انه نظام يعاني من قصر
النظر واضافت بون ان العقوبات التي فرضتها
ايران لا يمكن ان تقارن بالعقبه التي
فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه ان بطاريه القبه
الحديديه الاسرائيليه اعترضت صاروخا اطلق
من قطاع غزه فيما اشرت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه الى اصابه شخص بجروح بعد
اعتراض الصاروخ واطلاق صفارات الانذار في
مدينه
ومنطقه غلاف قطاع الى السحر
هذا هو شهدت السجون سجون الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي توترا بعد قرار وزير الامن
القومي اتمار بن جبير بحرمان الاسرى من
الخبز واغلاق المخابز في السجون التي كان
يديرها اسرى لتزويد زملائهم بالخبز الطازج
في السجون وياتي قراره بنجبير في اطار
سياسه حرمان الاسرى الامنيين من الحقوق
والمزايا والتجديد القيود التي تعهد
الوزير بفرضها قبل توليه لمنصبه هذا
ويواصل نحو 120 اسيرا في سجن النقب لليوم
الثالث على التوالي اضرابهم عن الطعام
احتجاجا على الاجراءات العقابيه والتعسفيه
التي تفرضها اداره سجون الاحتلال بحقهم
وعلى الرغم من حصول المقدسيه اكرم عميره
على ترخيص بناء من بلديه القدسة تابعه
لاسرائيل الا انه فوجئ صباح اليوم باغلاق
القوات الاسرائيليه مدخل بلدته وهدم
منشاته دون سابق انذار انتهاك ياتي بعد
اصدار وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
قرارا بهدم 14 منزلا ومنشاه فلسطينيه في
القدس
البلد موجودين وعايشين فيها وين نروح وين
نروح
بدهم يطلعونا وين بدنا نروح انولد نهاد
جماعي لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه على حساب
الحقوق الاساسيه للمدنيين هكذا يصف
الفلسطينيون اصدار تعليمات لهدم 14 منشاه
ومنزلا للفلسطينيين والتي تم تنفيذ سبع
منها في حي الطور وسلوان وجبل المكبر
ومناطق اخرى تعتبر حساسه واستراتيجيه في
القدس
انا جاي اه مشكل في حكومه اسرائيل ما في
علي عليك
المقدسي اكرم عميره تم هدمها على الرغم من
حصوله على رخصه بناء من بلديه القدس
التابعه لاس ودفعه رسوم الرخصه باهظه
الثمن الا ان وزاره الداخليه اصدرت قرارا
بهدمها حسب القانون احنا حملنا حالنا
ورحنا حسب القانون وجبنا اللي هو الرخصه
هي الترخيص حسب القانون
وانا ماشي ولما بنيت حسب القانون اجو
فحصوني
فقط بل على احياء كامله مهدده بالهدم
والاخلاء مثل حي بطن الهوى في سلوان جنوب
المسجد الاقصى في القدس المهدد بالهدم
لاستبداله بحدائق ثوراتيه لصالح
المستوطنين
هنا في قريه سور باهر في القدس تهدم
القوات الاسرائيليه منشاه لفلسطين قيد
الانشاء بعد اوامر وزير الامن القومي
المتشدد اعتمر بن جفير بهدم اربعه عشر
منزلا للفلسطينيين في القدس على الرغم من
المحاولات العربيه والامريكيه بالتهدئه
لان كلاسي من القدس العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا الان وفي اكبر اضراب منسق
منذ عقود والذي تسبب في تعطيل الاعمال على
نطاق واسع في بريطانيا شارك ما يصل الى
نصف مليون بريطاني من المعلمين وموظفي
القطاع العام وسائق القطارات والمحاضرين
الجامعيين بالاضافه الى موظفي الخدمات
المدنيه شاركوا في هذا الاضراب الاضراب
شهد اغلاق مدارس وجامعات فيما توقفت خدمه
السكك الحديديه في معظم انحاء البلاد وصلت
تاهب للجيش لتقديم المساعده على الحدود
كما نظمت مسيرات مناهضه لقانون جديد
لتقييد الاضطرابات في بعض القطاعات وهو
اقتراح يقول المعارضون انه سيزيد من توتر
العلاقات بين النقابات والموظفين من جانب
واجهات الاعمال والحكومه من جانب الاخر
[موسيقى]
من لندن نتابع مع مصطفى زارو مصطفى اهلا
بك معنا اكبر اضراب تشهده بريطانيا منذ
عقد تقريبا
الى اين الى اي حد اثر على مناحي الحياه
في بريطانيا وهل هناك المزيد من الاضرابات
حقيقه الملايين من المواطنين البريطانيين
لجاوا الى العمل عن بعد بسبب اضراب سكك
الحديد وخاصه ان بعض المحطات يعني اغلقت
مثل مثل المحطه التي انا يعني خلفي في هي
من احدى المحطات الخمسه الكبيره في وسط
لندن مغلقه تماما لا قطارات تاتي لها ولا
قطارات تغادرها حتى الابواب يعني مغلقه
تماما لا يمكن الوصول الى الى داخل المحطه
هؤلاء الذين عملوا من من بيوتهم اجبروا
على ذلك بسبب هذا الاضراب الضخم الذي لم
نشهد مثله منذ سنوات طويله بالاضافه الى
ذلك ان كانت هناك مسيره احتجاج في عدد من
المدن اولا للمطالبه بزياده الاجور وثانيا
للتنديد بهذا التشريع الذي يجري مناقشته
في مجلس اللوردات
يجد عرقله من قبل هؤلاء الاعضاء بالرغم من
انه تمريره من مجلس النواب بالتالي هذا
التشريع سيواجه العديد من العراقيل لا
سيما في في محاوله لادخال بعض الاصلاحات
علينا من موقف الحكومي كيف هو قيام
من اضراب اليوم والاضرابات القادمه
هناك اضرابات مرتقبه بالنسبه للمعلمين
هناك اضراب اخر في 28 من اشهر الحالي وكان
هذا تحذير من قبل النقابات اتحاد التعليم
الوطني وقالوا بان هذا التحذير للمسؤولين
يجب ان يقدموا زياده معقوله تتناسب مع
غلاء المعيشه والا ستمتد هذه الاضرابات
حتى الصيف المقبل هذا سيكون كارثيا
بالنسبه للتلاميذ والطلبه الذين عانوا
خلال يعني السنتين الماضيتين بسبب الوباء
وانهم يعني اضطروا
للدراسه عن بعد بالاضافه الى انه هنا
قطاعات اخرى لا سيما الممرض الممرضين
وايضا اطقم الاسعاف هناك يوم واحد مشترك
سيقومون بهذا الاضراب وسيؤثر على قطاع
الصحه شكرا جزيلا لكم مصطفى زورو مباشره
من لندن
وفي برد الشتاء القارس وفي وقت يواجه
البريطانيون صعوبه في سداد فواتير الطاقه
بتعدد كبير من البريطانيين يلجؤون الى
احدى المكتبات في شرق انجلترا للاحتماء من
البرد مع تخطي التضخم في البلاد نسبه
العشرات في المئه منذ اشهر
ملايين البريطانيين الذين اصبحوا عاجزين
عن تحمل تكلفه المواد الغذائيه او الحصول
على تدفئه كافيه في وقت تعاني المملكه
المتحده ازمه المعيشيه حاده
[موسيقى]
قال محمد عيسى انه لم يتم العثور على اي
وثائق اثريه في منزل بايظ خلال التفتيش
الذين نفذته وزاره العدل منزل الرئيس
اليوم واكدت وزاره الاعلام الامريكيه ان
التفتيش له علاقه بقضيه العثور على وثائق
اثريه في منزل بايدن تعود لفتره خدمته
كنائب رئيس اوباما وكان بيضا اكد انه
سيتعامل مع التحقيقات رغم ان تكون الوثائق
المكتشفه لديه لها طابعه سري
وبعد ان تزعم الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب في سنوات الحزب الجمهوري لا
يبدو ان الامر محسوم له هذه المره منافسون
كثر في الكواليس منهم من اعلن نيته للترشح
ومنهم من يحظى بدعم كبير لكن لم يعلنوا
ترشحهم بعد السفيره السابقه للامم المتحده
وحاكمه ولايه كارولينا الجنوبيه لكيلي اول
المنافسين لترامب داخل حزمه الجمهوريه حيث
تخطط هيلي للاعلان عن ترشحه للرئاسه
الرسميا في تشارلي في الخامس عشر من
فبراير الشهر الحالي بحسب ما اوردته وسائل
الاعلام امريكا
ترامب همم كلاهما يبدا مبكرا فما كانت رده
فعل ترامب
رد فعل غريب ومفاجئ حقيقه
اذ اتى جواب دونالد ترامب على خطه نيكي
هيليئه بالترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله بكثير من الهدوء والمنطق طبعا دون
ان يخلوا من تعليقاته اللاذعه الساخره فهو
اعتبر انه
يمكنها ومن حقها الترشح طبعا ولكنه تفاجا
لانها لطالما علقت بانها بانه طالما هناك
مرشح رئاسي قوي فهي لم تترشح وهو يستغرب
لانه هو المرشح الوقت
من المبكر القلب انه اي من المرشحين حتى
نفسه قد يحظى بدعم كبير من الجمهوريين
لانه من خلال متابعتنا للانتخابات
الامريكيه اذا ما تعلمنا شيء فهو نتوقع
المفاجات دوما في الانتخابات الامريكيه هم
يعلنون ترشحهم في قبل اكثر من سنه على
الاقل ودائما تحسم الامور في الاسابيع
الاخيره قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه صهيب
شكرا جزيلا لك للتسليمان مباشره من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه نزيف وتسريح
الموظفين في الشركات التكنولوجيه مستمر
فيصل تستغني عن الموظف
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد يستمروا نزيف تسريح
الموظفين في شركات التكنولوجيا في العالم
وفي احدث عملاقيه يخفض الوظائف هذا العام
شركه كيفال التي اعلنت عن التسريحي موظف
خطوه ستؤثر على حوالي 7% من قوتها العامله
العالميه سينما مع تخفيضات المحدده في عدد
الموظفين سيتم الكشف عنها قريبا بحسب موقع
اكسيوس الامريكي
هو بالفعل نزيف حاد في قطاع الشركات
التكنولوجيه الذي تعرض لصدمات كبيره بسبب
موجات التسريح بالجمله وتوجه الكثير من
الشركات الاعتماد على الذكاء الاصطناعي
نحن نتحدث عن تسريح اكثر من 316 الف موظف
في شركات التكنولوجيا منذ 2022 حتى الشهر
الاول من العام الجاري في الشهر الاول اي
يناير الماضي تم تصريحه اكثر من 75 الف
موظف بحسب بيانات
المتخصصه في تتبع الموظفين من شركات مثل
امازون مايكروسوفت جوجل وغيرها ارقام ضخمه
بالفعل فما السر
[موسيقى]
معنى من فريق دكتور حسن عبيد استاذ
الجامعي والبحث في العلوم الماليه
والاقتصاديه دكتور حسن اهلا بك معنا لا
طالما كانت شركات التكنولوجيا تمثل مثالا
للشركات التي تمثل بيئه امنه وتوفر ظروف
عمل ممتازه احسن من الشركات التقليديه
للموظفين فما الذي تغير
نعم مساء الخير يعني
ازيد على التقدير الجيد الذي ذكرته ان
هناك انخفاض حاد ايضا في القيمه السوقيه
لهذه الشركات فمثلا شركه ميتا خسرت اكثر
من 70% من قيمتها السوقيه من 920 مليار
دولار لاحول 330 مليار دولار جوجل مثلا
خسرات اكثر من 50% ابيل اكثر من 24% الى
اخره يعني هناك خسارات فعلا
رهيبه حتى في السوق الماليه لهذه الشركات
اما الاسباب
فاسوضحها بطريقه مبسطه الموضوع عندما اصبح
هناك في السوق والموضوع معروف في الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه فقامت ان شركه قامت
الحكومات بزياده معدلات الفائده ما ادى
بطبيعه الحال الى تحول الاموال من الاماكن
الاكثر همم خطوره الى الاماكن الاقل خطوره
وتحول الى الروس الاموال الى الاستثمارات
في القطاعات الاخرى على الخطوره وخوفا من
هذه القطاعات هذا واحد اثنان عندما زادت
معدلات الفائده بط الحلقه ان يكون هناك
اكثر ادخار واقل استهلاك وبالتالي القليل
من الاستهلاك يؤدي الى القليل من الانتاج
والقليل من المبيعات وبالتالي يؤدي الى
قليل من الارباح لهذه الشركات وبطبيعه
الحال عندما تربح اقل وتبيعها اقل بطبيعه
الحال ان تسرح الموظفين هذا امر ثاني
الامر الثالث ايضا الذي يمكن ذكره هو
ارتفاع تكلفت همم الموظفين او ارتفاع
الاجور والرواتب ما يؤدي بطبيعه الحال الى
تصريحهم وربما يمكن ان نضيف ايضا على هذا
الموضوع امور امور اخرى اهمها ان هناك تم-
عمليات توظيف كبيره جدا شاطره الكوفيد
وبالتالي اليوم لم يعد تعد بهذه الشركات
بحاجه لهذه الكميه الهائله من الموظفين
اللي بسبب رئيسي ايضا لعوده المستهلكين
للاستهلاك الطبيعي يعني اليوم
اصبحوا يظهر الى المولات وتخفى الاستهلاك
بهذا ال- بهذه الوثيره نعم هل هناك قطاعات
اخرى يمكنها استيعاب هذه الاعداد الكبيره
من موظفي قطاع التكنولوجيا المسرحين
هناك امران يعني الامر الاول يتوقف
الموضوع على المسرح نفسه على الموظف نفسه
كيف يمكن ان يطور كفاءاته لكي يذهب الى
قطاع اخر او ان يبقى في نفس القطاع ولكن
يقوم بما يسمى شركه ناشئه او ستارتاب وهذا
امر يعني بحقيقه الامر على الرغم من
سلبيته ولكن يمكن ان يلعب دور ايجابي جدا
في الاقتصاد الرقمي من خلال
المسرحيه اليوم 316 الف شخص منهم
المهندسين اصحاب الكفاءات الكبيره واصحاب
الخبرات الكبيره اعتقد انهم سيقومون بلا
شك
بانشاء شركات ناشئه للقيام بشركات ناشئه
تؤدي بطبيعه الحال اذا التقدم التكنولوجي
في السوق
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور حسن عبيد الاستاذ
الجامعي والبحث في العلوم الماليه
والاقتصاديه كنت معنا من باريس
[موسيقى]
حدث الفلكي نادر لم يحدث منذ نحو 50,000
سنه اي عندما كان العالم في العصر الجليدي
يستعد له سكان الجزء الشمالي من الارض وهو
عوده المذنب ذا تي اف الى سماء الارض ليلا
والذي يظهر بوضوح اكثر ليلتي الاول
والثاني من فبراير ووفقا واشنطن وسط يكون
من السهل القاء نظره عليه ولكن بالنظر الى
انها اللقطه الاخيره الاولى لجميع سكان
الارض الحاليين لذلك فان الامر يستحق
المحاوله علماء فلك قالوا ان المذنب سيظهر
للعين المجرده في المناطق التي لا تعاني
من التلوث الضوئي وان المذنب كان قد مر
باقرب نقطه له من الشمس في الثاني عشر من
يناير ويقترب والتدريجيا من كوكب الارض
الى حين يصل الى اقرب نقطه بين اليوم
الاول والثاني من فبراير الجامع
[موسيقى]
شهيده الرياض حفله تكريم الفنان السعودي
طلال مداح الذي رحل قبل اكثر من 22 عاما
تحت عنوان ليله صوت الارض
هيئه الترفيه السعوديه اكثر من 40 فنانا
عربيا من 13 دوله لتكريم الفنان الراحل
الذي امتد عطائه الفني لاكثر من نصف القرن
ولا يزال راسخا في ذاكره السعوديين
والعالم العربي
[موسيقى]
نكرم واحد من رموز الاغنيه السعوديه
الرموز المهمه الاغنيه السعوديه ومشاركه
الاساتذه الكبار في هذه الليله سواء من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه او من الوطن
العربي كله هذا يعني مدعاه للفقر والسعاده
ويدل على مكانه الفن السعودي والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه يكفي انك تشوفي الان انه
اسم المسرح اسم الفنان العربي محمد عبده
ويتكرم فيه رفيق دار ابو طلال مداح هذه
رساله للجميع يعني انا بنبسط باي هيك لمسه
من لمسات الوفاء لانه انا كثير بشجع الوفا
وفي ناس هيك بحس فيهم الروح بابا الاستاذ
طلال مداح من هالناس لانه خصوصي كمان
بتذكر انه بابا كانت الاغاني الخليجيه
اللي حافظها كانت قليله بس كانت وترحل من
ضمن الاغاني اللي كان بيرددها دائما فمدري
ليش هيك يعني بحس انه الاستاذ طلال الله
يرحمه في من روح بابا فيعني انا بحب هذه
النوع من الحفلات
معاه اللي بيكون عنوانهن شو الوفاء بصراحه
شيء بيثلج الصدر ويخلي الواحد عاجز عن عن
التعبير بصراحه شايف خيرنا صوت الارض همم
راح الكبير طلال مداح في يوم تكريمه همم
هو يوم تكريم لجميع فنانين السعوديه
والعرب بشكل عام يعني انا ممكن من اكثر
الناس سعاده وفرح همم بتكريم الاستاذ طلال
رحمه الله عليه لاني انا
يمكن عاشرته فتره طويله امتدت الى 32 سنه
قدم لي فيها في البدايات يعني قدمت له
الحان ايضا همم وعلى كم طويله يعني يمكن
بغالها حلقات عشان احكي عنها لكنني سعيد
وفرحان الليله بهذه الليله الكبيره
وبهذا نصل الى اختم اخبار الساعه اليكم
تذكيرا بابرزها
في اوكرانيا هجوم من نوع اخر كيف تشن حربا
على ايلون ماسك وتتهمه باخفاء التغريدات
والتلاعب بها لصالح روسيا
العربيه تتنقل في مخابيل اهم احزاب
المعارضه الايرانيه هجمات مستمره من
النظام واستفزازات لجر الحزب لصراع
العسكري
بعد يوم على زياره بلينكن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تبدا بهدم منازل ومشاه
فلسطينيه وبنغبير يحرم الاسرى من الخبز
بايدن ينجو من مازق جديد محامي رئيس يؤكد
وعدم العثور على اي وثائق سريه في منزل
الدلاوير بعد التفتيش الاخير
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه على صفحاتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]